- Thank you so much,
everybody, for coming.
Four o'clock, it cracks
me up that we can all
hang out at four o'clock and
get deep into some scholarship
and journalism.
But, before I before I
get into my presentation,
I want to thank Judy for this
really gracious introduction.
I want to think Dean Cohen
for bringing together us
50 or so scholars.
It's really an honor.
And it's been incredible,
for 10 days, to be together.
I also want to acknowledge
the incredible staff here
at Radcliffe.
Rebecca Haley, Meg Rotzel--
who has put together the
exhibition afterwards,
that I hope you will all join.
And we'll talk a bit about it.
And I'm not sure if she's
here, Melanie Cammett, who
has been an advisor
of mine for some time
when I was at Brown University,
and she's still a mentor to me
in the Kennedy School.
So I'm really grateful
that she's here.
And also Carol Hills, who is
a producer-- senior producer
and host-- at The
World at Public Radio.
We've never met.
We've been corresponding
for five years,
I've been on the
show a dozen times.
Thank you for coming.
But really, the people I want
to thank aren't here today.
And these are the cartoonists
I'll be talking about.
Because, at the
end of the day, I
can come here and have
a Radcliffe fellowship,
and share all of their work.
But so many of my
friends and colleagues
are in Cairo, in Beirut--
maybe they can't get a visa.
Maybe they're limited in
their travel because of funds,
or other reasons.
So really, I'm grateful for
the opportunity to be here.
But it's really a tribute
to them and their ingenuity.
So, without further
ado, my guiding
question-- my big question--
is why is there an Arab comics
moment now, in 2017, but
really, the past decade?
In this current
contemporary context,
why are comics so important
in a new, emerging Arab visual
culture?
I'll get to that.
But first, I want to
start with a question
that many of my fellow Fellows--
as this dorky turn of the
phrase we keep using--
have asked me about, which is,
what's going on in Cairo today?
I think that's what
all of these really
fascinating new colleagues
at Harvard have asked me.
What is going on in Cairo?
So, the way I'm
going to answer that
is through comics, obviously.
So, this first one is by
an artist named Shennawy.
He's in his 30s,
he's a founder of
this incredible comic collective
I'll be talking about today.
But this first image
is, for those of you
might have visited Cairo,
pretty recognizable--
the skyline, the
highway, the alleys.
But the key is what
it says on top.
You asked me, what's
Cairo like these days?
Here's the answer--
the translation.
Cairo, 60 years from
now, nothing has changed.
And I think that's--
the comic goes on
to be this very kind
of tongue in cheek
graphic narrative
about the comic artists--
60 years, and how
they're decrepit and old,
but they're still drawing.
But I think this is
a very powerful idea
to think about, in terms
of a country that's
had four regimes in five years,
and drastic political change.
And at the end of the day, it's
a city of 22 million people.
It's very difficult for a
city that large to change.
So, Cairo 60 years from now--
it's basically what
we're left with today.
But that's just one
comic and one perspective
on how Cairo looks today.
This is another--
Cairo of the imagination,
of the melancholia,
of the pharaonic imaginary,
the cosmopolitan imaginary.
The kind of Cairo you might
have seen in glossy magazines,
travel magazines.
And this is by a Lebanese
graphic artist, Lamia Ziade.
And I think in this
image, we could
start to see just how
cinematic comics can be.
And they can sort of create
imaginary or unworldly worlds.
But they can also
produce very real worlds.
This is a comic by a very
introverted graphic artist
named Mohammed Wahba
Shennawy-- different
than the first Shennawy.
And he has this
incredible lens that--
I mean, look how detailed.
If any of you have
visited Cairo,
you can imagine being
stuck in this traffic.
You can imagine waiting four
hours to get to the restaurant,
you're trying to
get to for dinner.
This is the Nile.
This is the Cairo Tower.
This is about 10 minutes
from where I've been
living for the past five years.
And this kind of freakishly
detailed cityscape
captures the intense urbanism
and movement of Cairo
in a way that--
I think-- only a comic can do.
Obviously it's just a frame.
But I'm giving you a
taste of everything.
Or, the totally simplified--
the stick figure.
This is by Islam Gawish.
He's an ultra-viral web creator.
He has, last I checked, 12 or 13
million followers on Facebook.
And he's known for these
sardonic stick figures.
And if you can imagine
this massive city,
this is how he sees one
street's chaos in the midst of--
whether it's protest
or revolution.
And in spite of it
being so simple,
the details are incredible.
He's walking over a dead body.
There's people being
beat up on one side.
On the other side
is further chaos.
And the stick figure,
perhaps like the artist
himself, just kind of strolls
along like, what can you do?
Now, just as a brief
aside, and gesturing
towards what Judy
was saying, Gawish
spent a night in prison in
2016 for his barb against--
allegedly-- Abdel
Fattah el-Sisi,
the military president.
But you never know.
And this is one of
the great mysteries
of an autocratic state--
why he landed in prison.
But we'll get more
to that later.
And so, what's
going on in Cairo?
Well, they're laughing
at us, is another answer
to that question.
This is by the
artist Doaa Eladl.
She's perhaps the most
prominent female cartoonist
in the country, which is no
small feat, considering--
even in the American context
or European context--
is a very patriarchal,
male-dominated field.
And she has
distinguished herself
as an award-winning cartoonist.
But also, you know, very bold.
She's gotten death threats
from political Islamists,
she's been sued, et
cetera, et cetera.
So, what I like to
say is that, in terms
of the political moment we're
experiencing in America,
I mean, the Egyptian
cartoonists get it.
They've seen this movie before.
They've drawn their
Sisi's, and they're
Mubarak's, and their
Morsi's, and everybody.
And this is just
more great material.
So, they're laughing at us.
But I would also
maybe use comics
to explain to you, more broadly,
the political situation.
So, we like to think of Egypt
as in this pharaonic world.
That, obviously, is quite
an imagined identity.
And I'm not here to tell you--
I'm sure we have incredible
ancient historians among us who
could tell us that
it's not a direct line
between the pharaohs.
But it's an important part of
Egyptian national identity.
And I think this is a
really brilliant, you know,
way to explain the
political scene that
far surpasses any
op-ed or research
article that I could write.
And perhaps one
that even brushes--
you know, obviously this is
quite making fun of the police
and making fun of authority.
But I want to show you one
that even maybe pushes further
against those red lines.
And this is a
scathing indictment
of the Egyptian state.
This is a family
covered in blood.
And it says, the
souvenir portrait
of the great Egyptian family.
A cartoonist named Andeel, who's
about 32, he posted this days--
not months, not weeks,
not years-- days
after the military coup that
upended Egyptian democracy
in July 2013.
So much of the
country was singing
with the national chorus of
a great military savior who's
overcome political Islamists
or the Muslim Brotherhood.
It was only a cartoonist--
only a cartoonist
could serve as an ombudsman in
this visually aggressive way.
And say, look,
you're all smiling.
But really, we have
blood on our hands,
and our faces, and et cetera.
So, again, this is
again moving towards
the political red lines, which
I'll talk about a bit later.
But the point I really
want to make here
is that cartoonists are
often this kind of canary
in the coal mine moment.
And while now, 2016,
2017, many cartoonists
have come out against Abdel
Fattah El-sisi, the president--
former general.
We have cartoonists
who are doing
it day three, four of the coup.
Which is pretty outrageous.
And it's not without push-back.
This is a Facebook
meme that, I think,
sums up the state of digital
surveillance or technology
in Egypt.
Which is this great--
this great contradiction
that social media
has opened up whole worlds.
Any cartoonist or
person with Photoshop
can create an incredibly
powerful image
with a stinging
political relevance.
However, with that,
comes surveillance,
and lack of privacy, and
activists and journalists
being monitored.
This started in May, in earnest,
that the Egyptian government
blocked 150 website, including
the website where Andeel
draws for, MadaMasr, a
leading independent news
resource in Egypt.
It's now over 400, including
websites like the Human Rights
Watch Arabic Edition,
a number of news--
even financial news sites--
of course, Al Jazeera,
which has been demonized.
I'm not going to
get too detailed
into this particular
spectrum of censorship.
I just wanted to say,
this is not an easy place
to be a cartoonist, and
particularly in this emerging
digital role.
At the same time, print
is really important.
And there is a cohort of really
talented and incredibly funny--
I think-- cartoonists who
work daily in newspapers.
Like Anwar, who's drawn
this, that I think really
captures the ambiguousness
of censorship in Egypt.
Because it's not like
one might imagine--
a man in a suit, and
a tie, and a red pen,
crossing out cartoons.
It's more of a crafty
cartoonist at the corner.
And maybe certain people
are unhappy with his work.
Maybe he'll get away.
Maybe he'll be coerced.
Maybe he'll have to
leave the country.
It's a very ambiguous fear.
And I think it's
particularly interesting
that private newspapers,
like the one that's
publishing his work, are
willing to go that extra length
and produce cartoons that
are incredibly bold--
in their visual language
obviously, and also
in their political message.
But these red lines are, as I
say, enforced very haphazardly.
So, that's going to
be one of the topics
I'll be continuing to raise.
So, here they are.
Let me introduce them to you.
These are some of the
so-called mad cartoonists,
as I've titled today's talk.
And these are just
the handful of them.
Some of their works
I just showed you.
Others, I didn't have such
beautiful photographs of,
so I didn't include.
These are by, by the
way, Benedict Evans.
He's an incredibly talented
portrait photographer
who I worked with in Cairo.
These mad cartoonists of
Cairo are using their pens
to redraw the lines
of acceptable speech.
And they often face resistance.
So, why do I call them mad?
Well, yesterday I had
the honor of sitting
through Art Spiegelman-- one of
the most talented comic artists
of the past generation--
speak, and he
spoke about how
deeply influenced
he was by Harvey
Kurtzman's Mad Magazine.
So, I feel like, OK, I
had a good title, now.
So, there's three reasons
why I like to call
these the mad cartoonists.
First of all, they're
mad at the status quo.
I mean, as you look at many of
the more politically-inflected
cartoons, they're
incredibly bold,
and there's no holds barred.
Second, they are- although
not directly influenced by Mad
Magazine--
are influenced maybe
by the generation
after the original Mad.
So they're part of
this comic collectives
that are quite raunchy, and
outrageous, and experimental.
So I do think they fit into
this kind of Mad Magazine
genre of alternative comics.
And for those of us who are more
analytical or science-minded,
I'll define all my definitions
when I get a little further.
But yes, these are quite
bold comic artists.
And they're mad
at the status quo.
And they're defiantly,
you know, they're
mad to be so defiantly
flouting of taboos.
And I think that's
the thing, is you'd
have to be mad to be a
cartoonist in this environment.
And yet, I've met
dozens of them.
And they're incredibly creative.
If they hit a roadblock,
they will work around it
and find a way to draw Sisi,
or find a way to mock whomever.
And they're really this
avant-garde network
of artists working in Cairo.
But, as all talk about
a bit later, they're
part of a bigger
constellation of artists
throughout the Middle
East, and North Africa,
and increasingly connected
to colleagues in America
in Europe and Asia.
Now, the most kind of clear
expression of alternative
comics, as we'll call
them-- comics for adults--
is this magazine called Tok Tok.
Now, this is the first
image I showed you, as well,
of Cairo 60 years from now.
So, Tok Tok is a horizontal
collective of artists.
They, serendipitously,
launch their somewhat
quarterly periodical two weeks
before the 2011 uprising.
So, it begins to
show the parallel
of how art and politics
work in tandem,
if not directly connected.
And they're deeply linked to
Egyptian art institutions,
to regional institutions.
And I want to say, above
all-- and I've just
said all this heady stuff
about how they fight red lines,
and are persistently
audacious-- but they actually
have a lot of fun.
They host great openings,
they host great get-togethers.
This is really a
creative insurgency.
And it's a lot of fun to
research and be a part of.
And here's some more images
of Cairo that, I think,
began to capture what
this city of 22 million
has to offer in
terms of daily life,
the minutia, the corners,
the alleys, where
you would leave your trash
out for the garbage men.
And this is why Tok
Tok is so unique.
Cairo is a very
class-based city,
Egypt's a very
class-based society.
These are liminal spaces.
These are not spaces
that get foregrounded
in daily newspapers.
So, for someone to be drawing
comics that really spotlights
what it is to live in
a lower to middle class
neighborhood of
urban parts of Cairo
is also a very
political statement.
Now, the name Tok Tok--
which you can see here,
for Arabic readers--
it's a three-wheeled rickshaw.
So, the urban
sensibility is deeply
embedded into the publication.
They're kind of like
really cheap taxis,
only available in,
what in Cairo is
called the popular
neighborhoods, which is,
in fact, the poorer
neighborhoods.
So, I think the
common thread here--
and when I'm talking about
how things work in parallel--
how sort of the revolution
happened and these comics
started--
this is on the eve
of the 2013 coup.
And they put out this
issue that, as I say,
foregrounds this
urban sensibility.
So, it's, again, I want to
start raising these questions.
So, this is the piece that--
I hope you can join at
the exhibition later--
I'll be showing, by an
artist named Shennawy.
I think it has it has an
incredible rhythm for us
comic scholars here.
The lighting is really special--
the way he's used
different shades and hues
to capture Cairo's
light pollution.
It's also a very
every-man's story.
This gentleman up here,
he's a car parker--
he's a valet.
And each issue, he kind
of experiences some kind
of absurd circumstances.
And I'm going to end the
talk with the most absurd.
But in this one, he finds
a young Chinese girl
in an alley in Cairo, and
decides to take her home.
But you kind of see Cairo
through this young girl's eyes.
She's maybe never
been in the city.
She doesn't know
why she's there.
And you just get these
glimpses of urban life.
But the thing that seems to be
the undertone of everything I'm
saying, is just how difficult
it is to be a comic artist
today in Egypt.
And I wanted to
draw your attention
to some of the kind of
pro-government rah-rah,
pro-Sisi hysteria, to show you
just how powerful the works
that I've just previewed are.
This is how the pro-state
official newspapers
show President Sisi-- driving,
literally, the ship of state
through the Suez
Canal, very handsome.
Here, he's on the cover
of a children's magazine--
kind of grinning.
I like that they've added
some friendly faces there.
Versus this image, which
was posted on Facebook
by a 20-something year-old
military conscript
named Amr Nohan.
Amr Nohan is now
serving in prison
for posting this on Facebook.
This appeared in the
newspaper, of Sisi
sitting on a journalist's head.
These are some of the more
bold critiques of him.
Sisi on the psychiatric couch.
Or an incredible Facebook
meme of the Mickey Mouse.
I wanted to show you
this slide to make
sure it's clear that these
mad cartoonists are outliers.
And since Sisi took power,
ostensibly in 2013, and then
through an election in
2014, the comic discourse
has shifted considerably--
day-to-day sometimes.
If there's a terror attack,
if there's an election,
the rules of the game might
change for a short period,
or in earnest.
But Andeel-- this cartoonist who
drew Sisi playing with action
figures, and kind of totally a
rambunctious approach to this
president--
he told me this.
Quote, "I don't want my work
to only be interesting because
of dictatorship.
Because this, again,
is giving dictatorship
so much size and importance.
I hate when people
see cartoonists
as exotic, the expression of
freedom fighters in the Middle
East."
So I always want to
bring in that kind of--
his dismissiveness, or his
natural approach to this.
To show that, although this
looks like a very intense
political act--
many of these cartoons-- they're
kind of just day to day life.
I mean, people have chosen
their career to be cartoonists.
And at the same time, the
stakes could not be higher.
Just this week--
it's very tragic,
and it's hard to
even think about.
That the lawyer-- a human rights
advocate, a lawyer in Cairo--
who works on forced
disappearances.
Which is, there's
tens of thousands
of people in Egyptian prisons.
We don't know why-- probably
for political affiliations
that are unsavory.
The lawyer working on
forced disappearances
was forcibly disappeared.
His name's Abdel
Moneim Metwally Hegazi.
And I think this
point of absurdity
is where the comic
artists come in.
I mean, it's very
difficult to make
a joke about something that is
that real, or that visceral.
But, in fact, that's
exactly the job of artists--
I think-- in this context,
and Facebook posters.
I threw this one in of
Sisi as George Costanza.
Because I think this is,
you know, online discourse
or, in the context of print,
is an incredibly powerful way
to attack a regime that's
disappearing thousands
of people.
And Egypt is, last I
checked, the third worst
trailer of journalists in the
world-- after China and Turkey.
Now, cartoonists are not
always considered journalists,
but many are members of
the journalist syndicate.
There's innumerable
risks facing them.
So, what are the red lines?
And there's no really direct
answer to this question.
Because, as I say, they
shift from period to period.
I've done extensive research
on Mubarak's red lines
from 1981 to 2011, and how that
shifted during a military junta
period, then during
Morsi, then during Sisi,
and then, how even each
year of Sisi can change.
But broadly speaking,
punching up or punching down,
two things we thought about
in the American context.
Punching up, in this context,
being insulting the president--
which is illegal--
Insulting the parliament,
the judiciary, the military,
a number of other
state institutions.
But, as I mentioned
before, it is all very
haphazardly enforced.
So its all part of the game.
And I just wanted
to-- this slide
was also my
opportunity to tell you
a little bit about my approach.
Because I'm approaching
this as a journalist.
I'm not a scholar of comics,
I'm not a political scientist.
So, I like to tell
people's stories.
I like to profile them.
I like to think
about why they're
making these choices, the
audiences they're reaching.
But I'm also not
an anthropologist.
So I don't go sit in cafes
and do reception analysis.
I don't do content analysis.
I don't do any of
these one techniques.
I'm trying to bring it all
together in stories that share,
I think, these incredibly
brave people's works.
So I conduct my research
at late night street cafes,
on university campuses,
secondhand bookstalls,
newspaper offices, museums,
antique shops, galleries,
salons, book launches,
festivals, workshops,
conferences,
symposiums, openings,
and quite crucially, closings.
Because when a place closes
here, we think it's-- oh,
the exhibition's closed for
after a month of showing.
But there's been
many cases in Egypt
where institutions have been
closed down, where publications
have been closed down.
The key point-- and this is
something that's emerged from
five years of my writing--
is that all of this censorship,
all of this pressure,
all of this stress, I think
it actually empowers artists.
And it is very
counter-intuitive.
And it's not necessarily
make-sense on paper,
but you hear this
in Andeel's voice,
about how he thinks he's
bigger than dictatorship.
You see this in the
persistent defiance--
and I'll get into the
deep history shortly.
I think all of these things
together make cartoonists
more committed to the cause.
So-- and I just
wanted to mention,
the risks are incredibly real.
This is a Palestinian
cartoonist who was gunned down.
And I put '88--
I apologize, '87 in London.
And the case is
still unresolved.
But it's also part of a
century-long tradition.
And it shows just
what's at stake.
I wanted to make
that clear to you,
who aren't working
in this field,
or aren't thinking about the
political aspects of comics
obsessively, like me and
a couple of my friends
who are here.
You know, why is it that regimes
are threatened by cartoons?
Why are interest groups
calling in death threats?
Why are Islamist groups bringing
lawsuits against cartoonists?
The fact is, that
all those people
are thinking about how
to coerce cartoonists
into changing their
perspective, means
that we as a general
audience, and readership,
and interested people, we
should be thinking about what
cartoonists are doing also.
So, this is a quick note
on my Herculean feat.
I'm Superman, but the villain
is much bigger than me.
And I'm trying to take
all of these ideas
and write a book about them
while I'm here at Radcliffe.
So that's going to be difficult.
But, as I've described,
I have a pretty good
idea of my argument
and my approach about how all
these difficulties, in fact,
galvanized cartoonists to make
their craft even stronger.
But since I'm a
journalist, I come
across all of these weird
characters and personalities.
And it's not just a
straight-up history,
although that's what
I'm very excited about.
But since no one's
actually written
the history of Arab comics--
although there's been bits
and pieces along the way--
I'm sort of forced to
almost survey that history.
So let me first give you a
taste of my secret weapon.
And then I'll give you a
little bit of that history.
So my secret weapon
is my archive.
And I have hundreds of old
magazines from the 20s and 30s,
all the way through
today, and books.
So this is my desk
over the weekend,
trying to write this talk.
You know, this is a
Mickey Mouse magazine
in support of
Gamal Abdel Nasser,
the great nationalist
leader of Egypt.
This is Mickey Mouse
making fun of Yemen.
This is a rip off of
TinTin from the 60s.
These are magazines from
the teens and the 20s
that have really
early caricatures.
So-- and this is me digging
through stacks of those.
It's a terrible photo.
But I just want to
give you a sense of--
just I have access
to book dealers
who have these archives.
And Egypt's a difficult
place to work in libraries,
and to get official permission.
So I've actually created my own
archive out of antique shops.
Although I didn't buy this,
because it was $10,000.
But it was an original
cartoon banner
from the 20s that was used
in a political demonstration.
These are bookstalls
that I peel through,
and digital archives,
galleries, graffiti--
these are all sort of
sites of my research.
And part of it's trying
to tie it all together.
But the thing I also
wanted to share with you,
because we are at the
Radcliffe Institute,
is Little Lulu in Arabic.
Because for those of
you who don't know,
Radcliffe has this incredible
librarian collection.
Among it are the full
papers of the artist,
Marge Buell, of Little Lulu.
And funny enough, you
know, she was born in 1935.
By 1965- 66,
translated into Arabic.
So, again, Art
Spiegelman, yesterday,
said that he learned
feminism from Little Lulu.
So, I don't know if
that's a bit of a stretch.
But I think many of
us learned feminism
from another character--
who Jill Lepore so brilliantly
about-- the Secret History
of Wonder Woman.
Now, I've learned that
Wonder Woman barely
appeared in Arabic.
I don't know why.
Maybe it's political, maybe
it's just an accident, maybe--
it's one of those
weird things that Lulu
is super popular
in Arabic, but you
can't find other random
characters in translation.
So I just wanted to acknowledge
also that, you know,
much of the Wonder
Woman's story was written
and happened here in Cambridge,
here on Brattle Street.
So it's cool to be a
part of that history,
and also to be writing my
own secret history of comics.
So what does children's comics
have to do with my research?
I'm still figuring out exactly
how it fits into the book.
But you have this
medium that's always
been childish and immature in
the context of the Arab world.
And it's only in the
last decade or so
that comics are really
coming out for adults.
And in fact, there's new comics
for kids like this adventure
story that's kind of
sci-fi, neo-pharaonic
that is obviously very informed
by some of these children's
comics.
So, as I said, because no one's
really written this history,
I'm just going to give you a
quick one-two of the history
of Arab comics--
or, why Disney has
been teaching young Egyptians
to smoke hookah since 1963.
I also want to
recognize a mentor
of mine, Elliott Colla, who's
a previous Radcliffe Fellow.
I showed him this slide
recently-- he's at Georgetown--
and he pointed out
that this is a hookah.
This is well-known.
This is just for hashish.
What was this-- why was this
on the cover of a children's
magazine?
I don't know.
This is part of the--
I've acquired all of
this incredible material.
A couple academic articles have
been written about this topic,
but I don't know who the
artist of this is, this cover.
Many of the covers
are not acknowledged.
So, yeah.
I'm really here to think
about this secret history.
But I buried the lead for you,
because I'm a bad journalist.
The first cartoonist in
the Arab world was a Jew.
This is the work of Yaqub Sanu.
He was working in the late
19th century in Cairo.
He was an
anti-imperialist crusader
and anti-government crusader.
Spoke more languages than I
could probably count, and ended
up having to flee
to France because
of his anti-government
cartoons in the 1880s.
But he still would
smuggle these.
This is the head of Egypt
at the time, the Ottoman
leader, the hadith.
He was skewering him,
drawing him as a pharaoh.
So it's this really rich
tradition that I really--
I like to show that--
we want to make
sure people know this wasn't
born out of the Arab Spring.
There's a really rich,
indigenous comic culture
that permeates all
aspects of print media.
And he was hugely influential.
He also wrote the first plays
in amiyah, an Egyptian dialect.
So, he published a huge
amount of satirical magazines
and publications.
And by the 20s and
30s, there's a lot
of humor magazines in Egypt.
And this is a political poster
that obviously uses caricature.
And some scholars are
working on this right now.
And they're exploring these
brief, historical moments.
And it's terrific
scholarship, in terms
of using comics
and visual culture
to explain the 20s
and 30s in Egypt
in a broader, post-Ottoman way.
But very few people
have thought about how
Tom and Jerry came to Egypt.
Now, this is from a very early
children's magazine in Arabic--
started in 1952.
Which is also an
important year for Cairo.
1952 is when the Free
Officers Movement--
a group of young
military officers--
overthrew the
monarch, and started
the new Egyptian republic.
So it's also very interesting
that, although not directly
related, that in this
moment of political change,
you would want to have
a children's magazine
to explain what is the ethos.
What should young children
be thinking about morally?
What should they know
about, politically?
And of course, the artists
just stole the best characters
from the US.
As an aside, this was always
Yasser Arafat's favorite comic,
Tom and Jerry, because
the mouse always won.
So-- and then, as I said,
you know, Mickey Mouse
has also been a part
of Egyptian culture.
This is already,
you know, 75 years.
And I think it's fascinating,
because we might think
of Disney characters as
symbols of capitalism,
or cultural imperialism,
or what have you.
But really, Mickey has
been fully integrated
into Egyptian culture.
These are all local covers
of the Disney affiliate
in the Arab world, which was
based in Cairo from the 60s.
And, I mean, very
pharaonic, this
is a kind of joke about the
Persian Gulf, or the Arab Gulf.
You know, different
folkways expressed.
Now you have that image
of him smoking a hookah
to add to that.
But yeah, very
interested in how he
became a very local character.
You see Mickey
Mouse, now, painted
on pre-schools and elementary
schools throughout Cairo.
I wish I had more time to
get into the deep history
right now.
I'm going to take us
way far in the future.
But I just wanted to show you,
so, there is this rich history
of children's comics.
And then it's taken up by
artists for adults and comics
for adults, starting in
the 80s and 90s in Beirut.
But, in terms of the mad
cartoonists of Cairo,
I want to bring us
up to 2007 and 2008,
when an artist called
Magdy El Shafee, who
was drawing for a prominent
opposition newspaper,
tried his hand at
drawing a graphic novel.
And this is the first
graphic novel in Egypt.
I mean, it's a
very big deal when
you think about,
this was happening
in America in the 60s and 70s.
And this is an
entirely new medium.
It's written in really
rich, dirty slang.
There's quite a
bit of obscenities.
And I guess, none of
us should be surprised
that all the copies of
this publication, Metro,
were confiscated
upon its release.
It wasn't widely circulated
in Arabic until about three
or four years ago--
and is available in translation,
if you'd like to read it.
It's a searing indictment
of the Mubarak regime.
This is drawn in the
last several years
of Mubarak's 31-year rule.
It's about the impunity
with which thugs operate,
with which businessman
control a kind
of crony capitalist system.
And this young
protagonist, who's
in his 30s or 20s, a
computer programmer,
is driven to the brink.
So I'm just going to read,
for you, the first line of it.
Because I think it's
incredibly powerful.
Today, I decided to rob a bank.
I don't remember when
I became so angry.
All I know is that everyone
was always going one way,
and I was going the other.
All I had on my
side was my brain.
So now my brain has a plan,
and I'm going to make it work.
And this gentlemen goes on
to use his computer skills
to rob a bank--
kind of secretly,
through wire transfers.
And of course, this is
the idea of him being mad,
you know, really angry
at the status quo.
But I was reading The New York
Times a couple of weeks ago.
There was an article
about, you know,
subsidized cooking gas being--
removing subsidies
from cooking gas
and removing subsidies
that are really
crunching a lot of Egyptians--
millions of Egyptians.
And there is a quote from
a woman in The Times,
"we don't know what to do.
Do they want us to rob a bank?"
I thought that was
pretty impressive,
that this graphic novel--
a decade later-- is still
kind of almost predictive
in these issues.
But what I'm actually
talking about
is not just about the
mad cartoonists of Cairo.
Its a regional phenomenon.
And Tunisia, Morocco,
and Lebanon--
which has been a
primary site of comics--
have had an outpouring of
creative interventions.
And I know here, I'm mixing
together cartoonists,
and comic artists, and
graphic narratives,
and graphic novelists.
I promised that I would
define all these for you.
But I'm not going to.
I'm just going to
say, all these people
are working on hybrid forms.
These magazines will
have one frame comics,
they'll have strips, they'll
have postcard-style drawings.
They're a total mishmash of
all sorts of graphic forms.
So I think it's
interesting to start
thinking beyond those
labels, in terms
of what these really
beautiful productions are.
And these are about,
I think, 17 issues
of this Lebanese
comic zine since 2007.
The Tunisian version is just
emerging in the past two years
or so.
And I think what's
noteworthy, is these
are all done by collectives.
These aren't individuals.
These are kind of the
anti-hierarchical, anti-regime,
in their make-up, even.
And, in a very similar
way, to kind of Raw,
and Zap, and even Mad Magazine,
these are groups of artists.
These aren't just
one single person
that makes these
publications come together.
So, is it political
escapism, though?
Are comics just
a way to run away
from the problems of the day?
And after all, I've told
you about the lawyer who
works on disappearance
is being disappeared,
that tens of
thousands in prison.
I mean, is Cairo just so bleak?
Is it so disturbing?
I mean, what can cartoonists do
that us and other professional
fields can't?
So the one thing I've noticed
totally unique to Cairo--
and, I mean, OK.
Totally unique is
an exaggeration.
But the defining characteristic
of Egyptian comics
is something that is--
can only be said is black humor.
The mobilization
of gallows humor,
literally in the
aftermath of an attack--
literally while the smoke is
rising from a terror attack--
cartoonists are
willing to make a joke.
And this is something
I don't think--
I think it's illegal in
France to probably say this,
je suis kouachi, the
killers of Charlie Hebdo.
I think no one in America
would have the gall
to post this or publish this
in the immediate aftermath
of an attack.
But here we are, one
month later in Cairo,
after the heinous
Charlie Hebdo attack
in Paris of January 2015.
And Egyptian
cartoonists are really--
they're well-versed in dealing
with blasphemy laws and terror
attacks.
And they're willing to come out
and make a joke straight away.
And I think this goes back
to the red lines idea.
Because in America
we have red lines
that we don't
always think about,
because they're not
legally enshrined.
But it would be considered
in very bad taste
to make jokes
about 9/11 on 9/11.
Whereas here, we have
a pretty bold joke
about ISIS that
came out not long
after ISIS had been founded.
And, "pardon me, chief... has
my head rolled through here?"
And this is the--
this is the ISIS-- it
just says ISIS Daesh.
And this just says barbershop.
It's like, you know,
what's going on here?
And this is but one
example of many,
that walk that fine line of
bad taste or irreverence.
And this is how to survive
a chemical warfare attack,
by a Jordanian cartoonist.
So it's not singular to
Egypt, but it is definitely--
Egypt's the center
of this black humor.
And in Jordan, you
know, this is how
you survive a chemical attack.
And, you know, but you might end
up like this anyway, even if--
Now, this came out right
when the Obama administration
was grappling with how
to reply or respond
to the Assad regime's alleged
use of chemical weapons
in Syria.
Is pretty bold.
I don't-- there were no American
cartoonists making jokes about
unconventional warfare
in this moment.
And here's one that
I often think about,
because it's an incredible
bravado to publish this.
"Sir, just pay for
the parking spot
before you explode the car.
Best wishes for Ramada."
This is in a major newspaper
with the circulation
of hundreds of thousands.
And this came out days after
the targeted assassination
and an explosion--
a car explosion-- of the
prosecutor general of Egypt--
you know, the attorney
general was killed.
The highest level terror attack,
in terms of an assassination,
in Egyptian history,
since Sadat's killing.
And this is what cartoonists
are saying the next day.
So what's going on here?
This is basically
one of the questions
I want to work on this year.
Where does black humor fit
into the tricks of the trade
of cartoonists in Egypt?
But the primary
thing I want to say,
is that it's a way to
symbolically attack--
and even level the playing
field with terrorists,
who have their own assorted
weapons and means of coercion.
But cartoonists retain
their power to punch back,
and to make fun
of craven killers.
And of course, it's not just
unique to making fun of ISIS.
It's also making fun of
the government itself,
and how they reply to
these terror attacks.
And this one is--
"another explosion?
OK then, prepare a
nationalistic song-- pronto!"
This, again, appeared
in this major newspaper.
I think this is in light of
the really heinous church
attacks that have
become a really
disturbing trend in Cairo--
not in Cairo, primarily,
in the outskirts of Cairo
and across Egypt.
But, yeah.
This is how this
cartoonist responded.
So, I'm going to close with
the same artist I began with,
Shennawy--
back to his car parker.
And now I just realized
we have a car parker here.
So, I guess for those who
are not familiar with Cairo,
terrible traffic.
And you often give someone a
buck or two to park your car--
not unlike any other city.
So this car parker is a
recurring character, as I said,
in every issue of this zine.
And so, we have
these cars kind of--
we've got these really
nice pickup trucks
and SUVs coming into Cairo.
And our car parker
friend is all ready.
He's parking them, he's is doing
everything, he's doing his job.
He's hoping for a big tip.
Except it's the founder
of ISIS, al-Baghdadi.
And ISIS has come to town.
It's not normal SUVs.
And it ends with our car
parker being beheaded.
Is it gory?
Is it distasteful?
Is it absurd?
Or is this how we can get back
at ISIS and regain our dignity,
or regain our--
what we have that's different
than these societies?
I don't know.
This all emerges from my
research and my interviews
with these artists.
But I just think they're
pretty mad for doing it.
And I'm really honored to be
sharing their work with you
today.
So, thank you.